you know one big reason I really want to
learn Japanese is one specific series I
want to experience after having learned
Japanese yeah and that's the monogatari
see oh yeah I've really really want to
experience the monogatari series after
learning Japanese cuz like I love the
monogatari series now yeah but I feel
like I'm getting like maybe half the
enjoyment I could be guessing and like
all the appreciation I could there's
this video I've been trying to write for
the longest time called you'll never
understand nishu Asian where because as
you said the monogatari series and
everything nice uation writes is [ __ ]
phenomenally he's an amazing author a
lot of it translates pretty well in
English right but the thing that makes
initiations so amazing is the subtleties
and the way that he plays around with
the Japanese language and that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] impossible to translate yeah
yeah and I wanted to make that video
because I [ __ ] love nice shoes you
know monetary seems like more than
anybody
yeah but it's like how do I explain to
my english-speaking audience about how
you'll never understand it if you're an
English speaker you have like a basic
understanding of kanji right yeah
understand not just kanji it's it's
everything he does wordplay in a way
that I have never seen any Japanese all
that noon and I think that's the whole
reason why so many people love him is he
was like it's like wow I didn't know
that you could lady makes Japanese
people's Japanese look Dom that's the
only way to describe a Japanese person
will read them be like wow it's like I
don't know this language cuz like have
you ever seen the Mona qatari series
yeah yeah I I was learning kanji the day
and I came across the Monica 3 country
oh yeah it's like 4 is it like Hana say
all or go which colleges are the one
where you it's like to speak or to tell
a tale is Holika oh yeah yeah gore is
like one of the meanings is to tell a
tale right and so it's like it and one
of the Tauri just means like thing tail
yeah yeah that's what I was like I saw I
look that's pretty cool yeah because
like because like that's the thing right
with the monetary series that even the
titles are a play on words
right because Bakuman more and
monogatari is two different words right
just [ __ ] mashes those two was
together to just turn it into one thing
and like that's that's like the
brilliant subtlety of
initially sure I don't want to say the
whole thing cuz I wanna see them for our
video okay so I was gonna ask how is it
reading the light novel compared to
watching the anime because that's
something I've always been curious about
how well the anime has been able to
translate his writing right into a
visual format I think with like that's
the one thing I love about shaft right
is that they do hold this like really
weird appreciation for initiations
writing and yeah that's why like you
know other doggies like monologues are
way longer than any anime monologue
shenoy like there's so much that's why
it being like what the fog like would
end like yeah like like a sedan Damona
guitar ii episode is like 95% dialogue
yeah but it needs to be because
everything that initiation rights is so
important to the story because it is
really convoluted and it does add a lot
of character and like and you know like
if you've seen one of Atari episodes you
know Holly every now and then there were
just like these flashing images oh yeah
that's all text ripped straight out of
the novels yeah I was really confused
that would happen yeah I've confused a
lot during about every series of the
manga yeah yeah I'm very surprised how
big monogatari gods because it like I
remember when I first watched it and I'm
like this breaks basically every rule of
like filmmaking conventions that I know
yeah it was like oh you know show don't
tell it what a guitar is like how about
we tell everybody and show basically
nothing and you're just gonna enjoy this
20 minute long dialogue yeah and you're
gonna [ __ ] in and and it's it turns
out amazing and I'm like why'd why does
this work I have never seen something
work so eloquently as the mornig atari
series and what surprised me is that it
just became like for the otaku culture
back then it kind of became like a
cultural phenomenon it did especially in
Japan because it was just unlike
anything and I mean you know caught on a
got that he in a sense as well I was
gonna say like if I had to if I was a
betting man I would have put my money on
cat on the guitar being way bigger than
yeah yeah yeah and it's kind of weird
that in the West it was like the other
way around and like people still don't
really watch I think Kapton I got to be
because of maybe it's like I don't know
where you can watch it all right
illegally yeah yeah I have no idea how
you have to buy like a four hundred
dollar blu-ray oh that's a shame because
there
banger it is [ __ ] it's got nothing to
do with the monogatari series just so
you know